Now I'm already off fucking track. You
know what my fucking bank did to me?
I walked in, I had this account
in New York that I kind of, uh,
it was a little checking account.
I had a little bit of money and then
all of a sudden notice they were taking
some fees out. I'm like, well, that
shouldn't be. So I get to New York,
I walk in, I talked to the douchebag
who works there and he goes, yeah,
they're taking $27 a month out.
I don't know why that is. Here.
Let me check to see what's up. Click
and click. I'll check on this thing.
And he goes, yeah, we shouldn't have
been doing that. And I go, okay,
well can you refund the money? And they
go, absolutely. Uh, and I go, well,
you know, I've had the
account for like six years.
Can we see how long you've been doing
this? And he's like, I'm sorry, our,
our records only go back
for four months. Really?
It only goes back for four months.
It's amazing because my bank records at
home go back the entire time I've had
the account and that's incredible.
And I just have some pithily some in
there while you deal with hundreds of
millions of dollars, if not
billions, if not trillions.
I don't know what the fuck you have.
I just know there's a fucking Bank
of yours in every God damn state now.
But of course it only goes back like
four months. So I go, all right,
well what if I bring my records in?
I look them over and I find out
how long have you been doing it?
And they're like, no, he can only
refund it for four months. I'm like,
two, what are you talking
about? And he goes, yeah,
well the bank kind of looks at it
like that, that that was on you.
What do you, and I was
like, it's on me to not to,
to not be like paying attention to make
sure that people are supposed to be
keeping my money safe, aren't
fucking stealing from me.
And He sorta like laughed. I'm like, dude,
this isn't funny. This is ridiculous.
You guys just stole from me. And if
you've been doing it for six years,
what's that? 270 bucks stare
at another fucking Nav. 50,
like almost 300 bucks
a year for six years.
That's like 1500 to 1800
bucks somewhere in there.
And the guy's just sitting there
fucking laughing and a, you know,
they say usual shit. Yeah. What
are you gonna Sue us? Go ahead.
We'll take some of that bail out money,
which is part of your tax
money and we'll fucking, uh,
so I dunno what I'm going to do.
I'm going to close out the
account and uh, and I dunno,
what do I do then?
I go across the street to one of
the bet for banks that are left.
If anybody out there is in banking,
how do I get my money back
beyond the four months?
Cause I know that they've been
doing it longer than this. Um,
can anybody explain that?
You know, this is why people,
this is why you don't put 100% of
your paycheck into the fucking bank.
He got to look at it this way.
If somebody mugged you last week,
would you walk up to the same person
and take your paycheck and stick it in
their back pockets? You
wouldn't, would you?
But for some reason we have these
fucking bankers. Yeah, I dunno.
I think everybody should
turn like, I don't know.
Everybody should have a fucking
safe that you have buried somewhere
everyday, but he's got a gun in.
Anybody can blow anybody away. I know.
It's all fucked up. Fucking assholes.
The guys sit in there fucking
smiling. Nobody sitting there doing,
he's doing that little twirly thing.
You know that math people do with their
pens and people who are in to finances.
I think they do it to
hypnotize you. It says,
the guy's fucking sitting there telling
me that they've been stealing 30 bucks a
month from me and all I'm doing
is I'm trying to focus on him.
I keep looking down at his silver
shiny pen, some sort of mind trick.
Fortunately I was aware of it. I said,
can you stop toiling your fucking pen?
But I didn't want to do that cause
I was trying to keep my cool,
which obviously is a difficult
thing for me to do, you know?
I don't know right now bill,
it's just 27 bucks a month times how
many fucking people you remember superman
three. When Richard Pryor stole half
a cent from everybody in the next day.
You had a fucking Ferrari.
These Fox are taking 27 bucks a month
from everybody. I'm convinced of it.
It's the fucking mob.
I swear to God the mob went legit
or those there will be blood guys.
They the fucking assholes
and run the Goddamn bags.
He's fucking constant just stealing
from me and there's nobody getting,
nobody's gonna help me. What
am I going to go down there?
I'm going to get that guy used to be
on the fucking, uh, leave it to beaver.
What the fuck was the name of that show?
Uh, Mayberry. I always hated that show,
that old content walking around with
their false set of voice. [inaudible]
okay.
You know, you know what? That show
lacked somebody that I wanted to bang.
That's why I didn't watch it.
There was nobody fuckable on it.
That was the brilliance of the
monsters that they were like,
this is going to be hilarious.
We're going to turn fucking Frankenstein
into drag and Dracula into these Kooky
characters and it's all going to be funny.
But they knew at the end of the day
they had to be somebody that a male
demographic would want to fuck.
So they came up with that
girl who was allegedly ugly.
Why am I explaining this
classic show? You know the deal.
And she looked like Marilyn Monroe
and that's what kept me in there.
I Dunno. All right. Batman.
After a while it's like,
do what is going on with this
40 year old guy in his ward
and then all of a sudden they had cat
woman walking around that fucking Horry
outfit. Is she the one
who started that shit?
Did women not dress like whores on uh,
on Halloween before Batman
or a bad girl or cat woman?
Cat woman was a bad one.
Right? This such pathetic cons,
you know what I mean? It's, we take
off that fucking ridiculous outfit.
Go stand behind a wall and, and,
and start talking to people and listen
to how many people even fucking pay
attention to you. They don't
cause you got nothing to say.
All you can do is just dress up your
God damn Twat and start strutting around
the fucking place that had
nothing to do with cat.
Woman had nothing to do with her.
It had to do with me fucking get fucked
over by that Goddamn bag. Assholes,
fucking asshole son. I got to go down
there. I got to go down there like,
like some fucking guy whose button
store just failed after 75 years.
You know, Frankie fish face and
sons remember those fucking um,
those businesses when you were
a kid, it was always something,
something and sons, you know,
and like a lot of the times the kids
were forced into the business. You know,
some Italian guy, he opens a fucking
prosciutto shop and then that's it.
It's like an arranged marriage except
that your job then you've got to show up
and be good and well, I have been
working in that ass, Toronto,
they did y'all Dah, Dah,
Dah, Dah, Dah. You know,
they don't know shit about anything else
is everybody wanted to strike out on
their own and now look,
everybody ends up in a fucking cubicle
working for these fucking cops who are
stealing my money. That's
uplifting, isn't it?